pearson a tenu en cette journée placée
sous le signe de l'amour à vous dire
quelque chose de très très fort c'est la
première fois en dix ans on vous fait
cette surprise jean michel regarde on va
commencer par ton ami jean-michel ouest
jean michel c'est ton ami dans la vie
c'est ton ami sur le plateau oui et on
voulait démarrer ce soir avec
jean-michel parce que jean michel c'est
vrai que c'est quelqu'un de très pudique
c'est quelqu'un que vous aimez
énormément c'est kaka qui est dans
l'aventuré avec moi depuis le début
mais depuis dix ans dont mathieu je sais
que c'est devenu ton ami vraiment ton
ami proche je pense que c'est un des
meilleurs amis si ce n'est le meilleur
aujourd'hui où il a sévi hier soir
encore et il m'a appelé deux fois
aujourd'hui pour essayer de serre escale
dans l'émission fera craquer surtout
sais pas je n'ai pas craqué ce que vous
ne saviez pas ce qui s'est passé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il sera à la hauteur exacte il est
maître sans filet et son slip
alors je vous le dis pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de tpm pays nous
allons entendre le son de la voix d'une
personne très proche de jean michel jean
michel pour cette saint valentin
l'amour ne pas avoir tout l'effort
un amour passionnel un amour fratricide
présidera un amour vous ne reprenez pas
que tu peux lui parler sur la fée des
dents et tu leur prends pas ça peut être
très précis doit bien sûr c'est l'humain
quel connard suis là à parler français
ban en deux minutes il sera notre tête
il a touché du doigt
ouais c'est vrai mais c'est parce que
c'est là son plein ce dimanche c'est ce
que fait l'état tu connaissais pas
d'émission quand même je bossais un
minimum quand même mon chou quant à
beauvais faudra mais franchement
franchement je sais je sais je sais pas
si ça va lui faire plaisir ou absolue
qui va être très émue
et comme il est très pudique à la
personne a tenu en cette journée placée
sous le signe de l'amour à vous dire
quelque chose de très très fort c'est la
première fois en dix ans on vous fait
cette surprise jean michel regarde comme
pape ou juste un message vocal de ta
fille chérie adoré pour l'instant moins
longtemps
voilà c'est pour te dire que je t'aime
énormément énormément tuer c'est pour
remercier d'être un papa aussi génial
pour moi et moi on peut en témoigner de
toujours être là pour nous et
j'échangerais pas pour rien au monde je
te fais des millions de bisous et je
suis très fière de toi dans ma vie
d'amour comme theodore et voilà je
t'aime très fort encore une fois et tu
me manque beaucoup
[Musique]
alors c'est votre fille mina cas quel
âge c'est ma fille mila qui a 19 ans
voilà et j'ai été très émue d'avoir si
on va jouer elle dit me manque je la
vois quand même régulièrement j'ai
déjeuné avec elle il ya quelques jours
mais c'est vrai je la vois pas assez et
c'est un chez un peu de l'ancienne école
c'est vrai quand mes enfants deviennent
grands comme mon fils qu'à 26 ans fils
romain j'ai un peu le tendance alors
laissé un plat laisser un peu voler de
leurs propres ailes et je pense que
c'est pas eu ce que c'est parce qu'ils
demandent et du coup je me l'obscur
pabis pour ça mais j'arrive pas à être
plus présent bon j'en suis désolé dans
sa partie conviviale et très souvent ah
ouais ce que vous avez envie de lui
répondre ce soir face à la caméra l
agrément l'étudiante en médecine fait
études ambassadeurs comme ça je l'aurais
avait commencé l'émission il avait 9 ans
elle était en cm1 et maintenant elle est
en deuxième année de médecine donc déjà
je suis très fier d'elle
on sait pas grâce à moi grâce à beijing
qu'elle a réussi le concours de médecine
c'est quand la mère constance que
j'embrasse énormément ce que celle qui
est quelqu'un qui l'a élevé de façon
magnifique avec qui lui a tout transmis
des valeurs exceptionnelles c'est donc
je suis vivement comme tous les parents
fiers de fier de mes deux enfants
voilà mais je pense que ça sentiment que
beaucoup partagent et je les vois pas
assez
j'espère qu'ils vont veulent pas trop
voilà je vais essayer d'être plus
présent c'est une résolution que je
prends là je l'essayé des plus présents
ce que je les aime tellement fort comme
tous les parents évidemment mais je
ferai tout pour eux mais voilà j'en fais
certainement pas assez donc je leur dis
que je les aime évidemment on aura tout
à l'heure un masque lover pour vous
aussi jean-michel en aura quelqu'un qui
viendra en surprise pour vous oui c'est
votre soirée ce soir on a décidé de
faire un petit mot sur ça finisse bien
sûr je suis très mignon c'est qu'il
dînait avec elle tous les mercredis
soirs ce soir là c'était même pas la
peine d'essayer de dîner avec jean miss
était réservé à sa fille sa fille lui
son bac mention très bien quand j'ai
joué je te jure t il son bac mois sont
très bien elle cartonne en médecine
c'est un amour et je dois dire qu'on
peut tout reprocher à jean mi mai quand
sa fille est là plus rien n'existe c'est
très touchant
[Musique]